recent report emerged
I think polygon was the first to report
on it saying that Marvel vs. Capcom 4
will be shown at PS X which is this
weekend and you know like which is weird
because I think it was late 2014 Marvel
vs. Capcom origins got pulled from like
ps3 xbox 360 marketplace they weren't
like Capcom wasn't completely open with
whether they would continue the series
obviously Marvel vs. Capcom 3 being the
last major entry but now it appears
according to a substantial report that
we will be seeing more vs. Capcom 4 at
PSX this weekend for all intensive
purposes so we kind of wanted to talk
about what we might see in that game
what we want what characters would do
well and like what character we won't
see because you know it's apparently
it's only Marvel Cinematic Universe
characters which excludes the x-men
which is kind of a huge blow to the game
did you play more vs. Capcom 3 a lotta
yeah I played a bunch of Marvel vs.
Capcom 3 and Ultimate Marvel vs. Capcom
3 which is I guess slightly newer than
that version they're gonna lose a lot of
I guess we'll start with that I guess
they're gonna lose a bunch of core kind
of characters that have been in the
Marvel vs. Capcom kind of series you
know you're gonna lose Magneto storm
Wolverine Sentinel these are some pretty
big mainstays that have been kind of
throughout some of them haven't been in
all of them but those like some of the
ones I named have been in I think all
three so it'd be interesting to see it's
not just x-men 2 it's like Deadpool and
then super scroll
I think cuz that's Fantastic Four so
because whatever Marvel doesn't have our
part of MCU yeah I saw people on like
Twitter saying that's the equivalent of
like if link and Pikachu weren't in
smash or something that's like the kind
of how big of a blow it is to this
roster but did you play much Capcom 3 a
lot P didn't play through so much but
I've been sort of you know I used to
play all the old 2d games starting you
know back when it was even just an
exponent fighting game right and then it
was Street Fighter vs. x-men and then it
was Marvel superheroes and it was
Street Fighter and then Marvel vs.
Capcom I played all of those and yeah
like x-men were a huge part of this
series like from the beginning so it
will be really strange to not be able to
pull up Cyclops and Wolverine right like
- pretty big omissions in my mind 3 I
kind of fell out of for some reason and
I don't know how I feel about 4 at this
point I don't really care about the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
not a lot I'm not in love with those
movies and I feel like what can I don't
know what do I want to see from Capcom
characters you know I don't even know
anymore like after five I feel kind of
apprehensive to get really excited about
another fighting game yeah I mean like
think about Capcom right now the closest
game that comes to mind right now is res
evil seven but that doesn't even have
like classic characters Chris Redfield
he was in three right yeah I don't play
much like many fighting is I remember I
played it for a little bit and I enjoyed
it just cuz I like a lot of Capcom games
and I used to be in the Marvel much more
than I am now like you Pete I kind of
fell out of cat like keeping up with it
which is why like I'm not crazy excite
about this either I think according to
report ant-man and Groot from guardians
of the galaxy are very likely characters
and man I have not seen but I saw
guardians the galaxy and I know GRU is
like a fan favorite so I'm sure there
would be a lot of jokes surrounding him
but I kind of wanted to touch on what
kind of like move sets they would have
as Eric as you're fighting expertise
goes what they might be reviewing also
like considering you know like they have
Wolverine Cyclops magneto are gonna be
omitted what kind of fighters do they
need now that those several x-men are
gone from the franchise one night I
don't know what's your taken like a what
kind of roles these new MCU characters
will fill if they are confirmed this
weekend that's tough I mean I don't know
how you do ant-man though because
ant-man like you know if you watch the
movie or if you follow the comic like
part of the reason he's so like such a
strong hero is because he can change his
size at any given time you can't change
your size to like this little speck on
the screen and then have to deal with
that I think that's kind of insane you
can't feel like ultra moves though right
yeah I guess but I mean so ant-man
wasn't Ultimate Marvel vs. Capcom 3 but
he only showed up when Hawkeye used him
as his like level 3 super huge shoot
ant-man off the tip of his arrow and
then a man would turn into it like a
giant and then smash someone so I don't
know how ant-man would work cuz like
fighting rocket racoon and Marvel vs.
Capcom 3 was already like super annoying
cuz he's super short so his hitbox is
like really small and so like a lot of
moves I normally hit people don't hit
them so I don't know how ant-man will
work so much Groot I would imagine is
just one other you know kind of
he'll probably bigger and he'll be
taller I will slower yeah he'll be like
slower but he's gonna have like reach
and he'll probably do like big damage
and he probably could take damage and I
guess you can kind of think of some of
the stuff he can do just tumors of like
the movie
I guess cuz guardians of the galaxy and
I don't know I think it kind of makes
sense though cuz to have a more verse
Capcom for because I feel like the
longest time was would Marvel be okay
with it yeah more so than Capcom willing
to do it cuz I'm sure Capcom wants to do
it right and I think from Marvel it
makes sense just because all these
movies keep coming out they're doing
like one every year or maybe more than
one once a year right and because of
that they probably can capitalize on the
fact that a lot of people are watching
these movies falling in love with these
heroes and want to play them in said
game what has me worried about Marvel's
success since um c3 whatever that game
it felt like a very much a Capcom
fighting game right but like now Marvel
has so much at stake with these
characters and with this game like how
much control are se are they going to
have over the visuals over you know
different things like will this be a
Capcom joint or will this be a like
collaboration in a way that I think
people might not like yea Marvel's got
that high forget how long that road map
is for the MCU and it just stretches
like at least 10 years from now with all
the different spin-offs and all the
different heroes incorporated now that
like and man's around there's guardians
galaxy 2 was that officially announced
yeah that's coming like next year or
something and it does seem like they're
kind of much more like the control freak
than Capcom is especially considering
Capcom I've mistakenly said that
Resident 7 is the next game we have Dead
Rising Frank Wes was a character in
Jeff's game he was I'm sure he'll make a
return especially if he's in dead
writing for
but again I can't I can't think of any
like new Capcom characters that might be
coming along for the roster well Moira
from revelations to Barry Burton would
be awesome no I don't want Moira she
would just offer Lee shout expletives
for no good reason
characters from the Baker family from
resi Wilson was just that for their
ultimate I mean I think that trying to
find new Capcom characters would be hard
outside of like maybe Street Fighter 5
maybe you try to pull like a Rashid in
there
or one of their newer characters that
they didn't have previously in Street
Fighter but they can also just go back
right like there are some characters
that got emitted in three that were in
two that were pretty big like captain
commando brigly auto man yeah exactly so
there's there's plenty of characters gin
no you know so and they can even go
farther back if they wanted to like
rival school stuff and why not right
would love that
yeah so like this could be their chance
to like bring back some of those older
franchises that they maybe can't just
make a new rival schools or Darkstalkers
even like they've had multiple multiple
dark stalker characters throughout these
Marvel vs. Capcom games and you know
it'd be cool to see some of those people
come back like John Taliban or something
he would play fine I think in in a
Marvel vs. Capcom world
Demitri would play fine cuz he's almost
like the ryu of that game you know so
there's a lot that they can go with
wonder if Marvel can say to Capcom no we
don't want that character fighting our
characters I wonder if they can go that
oh I hate to speculate sooner but I just
really like I really want to know how
this new Marvel is going to handle a
collaboration I feel that they don't
usually work in yeah I feel like I think
I don't know maybe this is just me being
really open about it I guess it's just
like more as long as they stay true to
the Marvel characters I feel like then
that's where I would expect you know
they're kind of angst about it it's like
okay
make sure Doctor Strange is Doctor
Strange make sure you know these
characters are these characters and we
can just imagine that this world is like
your characters get to fight our
characters but you got to make sure that
our characters are the way they're
supposed to be and you can have your
characters yeah right no of course I
understand we were saying but like you
could isn't like there was like a baby
in like one of the Capcom fighting games
Kimber what it isn't
I think maybe it was just like it was a
sidekick to another character I could
just imagine Marvel saying like we
really don't want this little puny guy
beating up our superheroes you know who
knows I have to imagine I mean like they
were just the some of the gameplay that
we were just watching showed like the
nemesis from resi be they get like they
that's not the deepest cut but they go
pretty deep with some of these
characters I'm wondering like I said
would between Dead Rising 4 or as evil 7
I don't know like it's tougher cuz it's
an RPG but I wonder if they'll pull from
Monster Hunter now
if that would be a hunter or something
just like a generic kind of character
like that I have to wonder like what
Capcom and Marvel will be doing is
Marvel obviously there's ones you can
safely assume will be really Captain
America Thor they'll be here least of
all because their movies been doing
really well
Iron Man will be around yeah he's been
in a bunch of um also I guess the other
side question I have not to get to off
tangent is that if this is something
that's gonna be at PSX is this like a
Sony exclusive thing again and is or any
of those characters gonna make it in I
think it's gonna be a PSX because
there's a Capcom tournament oh yeah
capsule is a final recap Conroy yeah I
think that's a coincidence well yeah sex
does announce like not exclude things
but like yeah when you look back the
last fighting game Street Fighter 5 was
exclusive for how long Yeah right yeah
that got announced that PSX 2 from I was
talking to John Luke about it earlier so
this year you have a Capcom end that
they did not sell enough copies of
Street Fighter 5 like they think they
needed biggest audience secured their
hands on I'm sure Marvel wants to hit
the biggest audience as well
all right yeah I'm pretty curious to see
how that shakes out I imagine the
licensing issues for like combining
something like this not that it's their
first rodeo but it just must be a
nightmare you have both parties want to
creative say over it despite the fact
that Capcom someone developing it it's
gonna be there's all these shows all
these movies just expect those like
don't be shocked if you see like black
panther there though you know so like
Punisher like see when you name all
these and I'm thinking of these like I
like the first season of daredevil I
haven't watched Luke Cage yet like I
wonder if like Jessica Jones will be in
here something don't you want these
accessories drinks whiskey and people
don't you want these characters to look
like the comic book version of these
other characters like if you saw the the
The Punisher that we know from like
modern media I would Jane yeah I don't
know I don't even follow that often but
I would feel a little bit betrayed to
not see the Punisher that I knew growing
up yeah but I mean it'd be probably more
that than the TV show I guess I hope so
yeah I resemble the movie or the TV show
that's Marvel doing really yeah like
they're just disgracing their current
effort well that's the thing I would
imagine like Iron Fist is gonna show up
cuz his show is coming out soon I am
worried because when Marvel vs. Capcom 3
was released this MCU like
roadmap was not in place there were a
few movies I think Ironman had been out
by then the first Thor maybe I can't I
can't remember which movies were out but
now there's I think there's two a year
two Marvel movies a year seems like
breaking ball and now again how much is
this just gonna be marketing push for
Marvel's efforts some of those
characters technically like even Iron
Fist was already in three yeah and Thor
was in three Iron Man was in three by
Iron Man's been dealing a lot of them
like since the like way beginning so
like that's not too weird
it's a Deadpool can't be included he's
not he's Spock's I'm pretty sure all
right well wasn't Spider Man Sony for a
while but now I think Marvel has it back
because he's yeah Marvel got spider-man
back so Iran is like too big you know
yeah so on that no I'd love to see
carnage he hasn't made any of the games
any of these fighting games only venom
has so like Jeremy Renner's Hawkeye it's
useless for most of the movie game no
I'm just kidding Hawkeye was pretty good
in three and more games just saying man
alright well unless there's any other
points I think we've exhausted the
Capcom Marvel discussion but yeah so we
will see this weekend we have a couple
people Justin
sorry not Justin Jake Decker Randy and
some people are going down to PSX
doesn't matter who put on PSX was in
Anaheim this year as opposed to San
Francisco like it was last year but we
will have more news out of there like
likely we will see you Marvel vs. Capcom
4 and we'll have more to talk about once
we see that announcement so leave your
thoughts in the comments below what kind
of characters you want to see which do
you think won't appear and what your
overall thoughts about potential for
Marvel vs. Capcom for
[Music]